you do seem to have cornered the marcus
in that kind of you know that or bein
gay man yeah I know that's weird isn't
it yeah how did you discover that you
were good at that
well that's a long story conversation
yeah if you'll just excuse us for a
moment you know I don't I don't know
when I you know when I was cast in the
in The Devil Wears product which which I
heard recently that that you auditioned
for the role did I did I hear what you
feel about Winona Ryder yes I did
I just I have spent my life preparing I
no more chance of getting her oh but
just to be just so you know I was
probably the last actor in Christendom
that they went to they were shooting the
movie already they had been they had
tried to cast everyone than anyone
except me and in the end
[Applause]
it could be not for the road but but but
what what they said to me was it was
between you and me yeah why you know why
the urbane I don't know why but you've
got that very late in the day so you'd
know yeah they were shooting the movie
already I had three days and sometimes
people who aren't gay are better at
being gay than people who are should be
so good yes there's a certain
objectivity there's a perspective that
maybe you wouldn't have liked playing
lesbians I have a lesbian but I don't
like playing them I loathe kissing women
for example on stage or on screen uh-huh
absolutely loathe it and I tell you why
and I'm quite serious it's because I
don't want them to think that I fancy
them can you understand that well that's
exactly why I don't play lesbians on
stage
[Music]
you